let's talk about folk art real quick now
these days folk tends to be more
associated with things like Simon and
Garfunkel but here's an interesting
observation
Simon and Garfunkel art folk they're in
the style of folk now why split that
hair because folk art actually has a
specific meaning and that's in reference
to art that isn't created by any one
person in particular folk art doesn't
really have an identifiable author
beyond the community as a whole and
importantly it's not created by focused
professionals folk stories for example
are generated over years by people by
folk adding adapting misremembering and
word-of-mouth in a story from person to
person to person as a result these
stories tend to be unfocused meandering
oddly paced infused with strange logical
leaps fantasy elements that don't really
adhere to any coherent rules and all
around generally showing the signs of
being the crowdsource of product of
amateurs and in a lot of ways that's its
own awesome thing and is part of the
appeal and this is kind of how I feel
about the learner I'm not saying that
the lore feels like something
crowd-sourced by amateurs but that it
evokes a lot of the same jumbled end
result the lore is a Polish synth pop
musical abstract fantasy horror about
stripper mermaids who go through life on
the surface dealing with mermaid
problems like trying to get some action
all up in your cloaca because your human
parts are to quote the film's opening
scene as smooth as a Barbie doll
as an example of this jumbled fairy tale
folklore sort of structure at one point
the sisters get into a fight where they
hiss at each other and bounce off the
walls
the fight is ended when their landlord
punches them both in the face knocking
them out cold he and his family which
includes the primary love interest by
the way then roll the sisters up in
carpets and drop them off a bridge an
indeterminate time later the sisters
crawl out of the river kill two dudes
eat their hearts and show up the back of
the strip club to confront him and all
is forgiven after the brunette sister
bites his thumb off now I enjoyed this
movie I think it is the Little Mermaid
if the Disney version never existed but
they still wanted a musical because the
screen
writer had a really big across the
universe phase and if you've seen across
the universe and you watch the ler you
will notice that it's a very deliberate
comparison I'm making here what I'm
saying is that it's worth seeing if only
because there's almost nothing else out
there remotely like it and that alone
makes up for a lot of the flaws like an
inscrutable plot haphazard use of
symbolic non-diegetic musical logic
really inconsistent subtitling and some
stilted acting style does eventually
take its toll on substance the
hallucinatory logic of musical
short-circuiting a lot of the second act
but there's still something compelling
in there even if flawed also side note
between men and chicken nuts and the
lore cuff this year had a real subtext
of human animals sex hybrids